what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like Marvel
Studios might be trying to pull a fast
one on us as we have some news about
Doctor Doom today now first and foremost
I must state that I have seen black
panther wakanda forever but no I will
not be spoiling anything about the movie
in this video or any videos to come
before the movie actually comes out and
if I were to talk about any spoilers of
the movie of course I would say
beforehand spoiler warning so don't
worry about that however I will say this
there was a lot of speculation about
what could be going on in wakanda
forever and there was a lot of talk
about certain really big MCU villains
possibly showing up and being introduced
possibly in a post-credits scene I think
you all realize who I'm talking about Dr
Doom and while I'm not going to say what
the post-credits scene is I will say it
definitely sets up a lot of things for
the future that could possibly happen
however it doesn't have to do with Dr
Doom but Marvel might actually be
tricking us on that one I've heard from
insiders that Marvel Studios did indeed
shoot a post-credit scene for black
panther wakanda forever that did involve
Dr Doom now what's interesting about
this is that this somewhat happens
actually kind of frequently for example
Marvel Studios actually shot multiple
scenes with other members of the
Illuminati for Multiverse of Madness
that we never saw like Ghost Rider they
shot a scene with Ghost Rider it never
made it to the movie and didn't even get
released in a deleted scenes clip we
don't know why things change we don't
know why things get removed but
sometimes it does happen and here's the
really interesting thing we only saw one
post-credit scene in Black Panther
wakanda forever just one whereas
normally there are two so if part of me
thinks that they are withholding a
post-credits scene from The Press at the
Press screening at the world premiere
because they don't want the Doctor Doom
post-credits scene leaking they don't
want it getting out there now I'm not
saying to expect a doctor doompa's
credit in fact I wouldn't because let's
manage our expectations here so we're
not disappointed however hearing that
they did shoot a scene is very
interesting however there is some news
coming from some insiders over the past
couple of days that state that Dr Doom
might not even be a villain of the
Fantastic Four film now keep in mind we
have no confirmation from Marvel Studios
or any major trade Outlets like deadline
or The Hollywood Reporter that Dr Doom
is coming anytime soon the reports have
mostly came from insiders and granted
insiders can be right A lot of the time
Marvel Studios can also change their
plans however I don't think Marvel is
changing their plans of course it's a
possibility but we know that Kevin foggy
likes to be original and he doesn't like
to repeat things that have been done
before and we've had three Fantastic
Four movies that have already had Doctor
Doom as a villain now don't get me wrong
I'd still love to see him as the main
villain of the new MCU Fantastic Four
however Kevin feige like I said
typically doesn't like to repeat what's
already been done so the fact that in
insiders are reporting that Doctor Doom
may not be the villain of the Fantastic
Four movie doesn't really come as too
much of a surprise however do not let
that discourage you about possibly
seeing Dr Doom in the future relatively
soon because yes Dr Doom is an iconic
Fantastic Four villain but he is also an
iconic villain in Marvel Comics just in
general and let's not forget that
essentially God Emperor Doom is the big
bad of the secret War storyline in the
comics the storyline that we are leading
up to so it does make sense for Dr Doom
to be entering the MCU relatively soon
but also one of the great things about
this is that hopefully Dr Doom is going
to stick around for a long time way
after phase six we know that the mutants
are going to come into play in phase six
but not in a huge way that's not really
going to happen until phase seven in
Phase seven the main characters of the
MCU that they focus on are going to
shift from The Avengers characters to
characters like the mutants and the
Fantastic Four which of course would
include a Doctor Doom villain and this
is great because Dr Doom is way too big
of a villain to just have for one phase
if he does indeed show up for a
post-credit scene for black panther
wakanda forever if they decide to
actually include another one a second
one that has him in it then that would
mean he would be in the MCU for two
whole phases phase five and phase six
hopefully all the way up till Avengers
Secret Wars this would be a lot of time
however I still think he should remain
in the MCU after facex because he is
such an iconic villain since Marvel
Studios usually does two post-credit
scenes and we only saw one I do hope
they are saving a second one for when
the movie actually releases in theaters
and they're hiding it so whatever it is
doesn't get revealed or leaked too early
because let's face it we know that it
will maybe they will and maybe it's
Doctor Doom maybe it's somebody else
again don't go in expecting to see that
don't get your hopes up but maybe if
we're lucky Marvel Studios was hiding it
and maybe we'll get it but let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below are you okay with Dr Doom not
being the main Fantastic Four villain
for their MCU debut movie and if you are
who would you rather have be the villain
of the Fantastic Four let me know in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay up to
date on all things relating to the MCU
for live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof